hello everybody and welcome to another
amnesia custom story this one is called
abduction I have no idea what this is
about
so all I have to go is this little
message here you are startled by a loud
crash in the middle of the night
investigate the source okay sounds good
I'll do that
Oh bring it on
huh it was a loud crash in the middle of
the night I wonder what it was okay what
I sleep by my bed not on my bed okay
whatever all right
lantern thank you thank you much key yep
I need to get a key to get out of my own
bedroom is that how this works yeah
cheer good app open up this open up that
up nothing what's in here oh okay all
right
yep thought so if I lock my own door for
safety cuz there inevitably gonna be
monsters who was that who made the noise
downstairs that's the name of the entire
area downstairs all right bring it on
come on now Oh who is it oh look at all
these chairs Oh any monsters going down
down way down Oh
who wants some oh so ready for you huh
okay the monsters yet they're all scared
BAM smash oh it's my house I'll do what
I want that's right
Oh Super Deluxe chair up more some damn
son Oh BAM boom yeah that seemed about
right
okay a whole nother area foots
that's that's how I defend I identify my
house
it's bedroom downstairs and then food
storage and something about right okay
plenty of oil boxes whoa oh right yeah s
you get out of here
barrels boxes empty stuff nothing useful
a mouse oh wow what the [ __ ]
Wow come on
oh I'm a David uh ah was that supposed
to happen cuz you wouldn't let me get
away gonna get for putting down my box
Oh fu man you did that on purpose
ah I'm so gonna kill you and all your
friends or I'm gonna run away screaming
I wrote down a note I'm surprised you
even let me have a new where am i my
lantern is gone I must find a way out of
this horrible place
horrible Ori bleh alright anything under
the bed just a roach bucket a very badly
hurt and I'm going insane ah all right I
cannot see anything
it is very red nothing in the bed
anything in here go dump
nokey donk
oh that's the goopy stuff squish oh here
we go
who's this let me uh let me uh let me uh
come on it's gotta be something bonk
bonk bonk nothing I just lost my bucket
ah am I supposed to do
can't see a darn thing
aah let me out you out of here please
let me out there's a dead man over in
the other one box in a box here some
what this nope not a thing oh man
it's a box here thank you something with
these um yeah well huh yeah pretty much
expected I'm lost
though big whoop okay all right I got it
I gotta figure this [ __ ] out
the lever or something loose brick maybe
there's a squishy pile of stuff boxes I
can touch over there there's one gap in
the bars here but doesn't break or
nothing No
alone let me out
let me go help um up yeah this makes
sense
this phase up there I can pile boxes up
if that didn't do anything there's a
pile of goop here for some reason and
I'm lost
why am i lost why let me out
oh this is boring I'm bored
okay I gotta be looking at this the
wrong way I mean seriously I must find a
way out of this horrible place but where
is the way out I have nothing in here
well my sanity and health are back
finally and there's nothing here there's
nothing here
there's nothing nothing here
your actions have made it potentially
impossible to escape this cell ah fu
what what the hell is your problem
fine ah fine uh oh come on you're
kidding me
what oh [ __ ] Kyle's wrong okay
all right trying this again without
failing hard core okay
these boxes are inherent to my survival
so I get um my take um I'm gonna keep um
and this not gonna beat me no fuse all
right
so supposedly I'm guessing I'm supposed
to stack these up for some reason what
reason I don't know I don't know okay
crawl out this way oh you gotta be
kidding me oh you have got to be kidding
me
huh ah okay I'm okay
no is it subjects response to new strain
of formula was lesson optimal blah blah
blah blah so much feels control shackled
to table eyes rolled up upon death
leaked green substance from every pore
and hole on his body
laughs that's lovely yeah okay that's
some
hello dead guy nice ass
alright what do you want what are you
yeah alright okay
moving on without getting lost again
moving forward ah oh my goodness it's so
scary not huh people think they could
scare me and just because I was scared
just a few minutes ago doesn't mean that
they can scare me quiet shut body parts
alright bring it on dungeon halls I
don't remember there being a dungeon
hole in my house whatever what do I know
all right oh yeah here
Oh monsters I don't have any lantern I
can't see a thing
the door here Emily alright
nope nope nope can't see a thing
what is up was I supposed to find a
lantern already did I miss a lantern and
I just failing hardcore this let's play
yeah yes yes yes and all accounts yes
let me just look again cuz it probably
was being a big dumb idiot
alright bestir wasn't in the chest none
there now behind these barrels not up
here not over there not in the body
parts not on the table not with the dead
guy okay so there is no Lantern here uh
yeah okay alright
okay so I just have to walk in pitch
blackness sure that's scary but it's
more of just annoying dork
get me a lantern gift give me a lantern
it's spin it what's the point of this we
this is fun yay yay all right uh hammer
mind the hammering chipper I did I did
not you combined it
this is cabinet we got here a lantern no
oil
thanks for the oil I'd really like a
lantern to go ah there we go
finally finally oh man making a fool out
of myself on this let's play all right
couldn't give me me a lantern with some
oil in it big jerks all right move it
whoa huh hey hey hey hey hey now you
back right off huh what what what what
the hell no no no no get out of here get
oh ho close the door on you up loser get
out of here no one likes you anyway your
big dumb and ugly aah
gotta go do I do Oh back off you can't
do anything to me oh oh what's that oh
you're here behind the door that I need
to go through to get out of here but for
right now I win this is acid in isn't I
should touch it
yep hold some soda acid go away go away
get out here you can't see me
I win you lose sweetie Oh where'd you
get bigger yeah try harder next time
buddy
oh just you wait until I have a chair
good you go okay ah hey back off
Oh back oh oh you want some oh oh get
get gone
ugly oh I'm coming out to getcha I'm
coming out to getcha
Oh bring it on I'm guessing these guys
don't do da
Geyer barrel barrel oh yeah run hey run
hey run guy oh oh oh
darkness provides cover Yeah right it
did not ah man this is officially the
worst part one I've ever done in my
entire life sorry to say all right I'm
gonna pause it here thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you in
the next part bye-bye